loving China but hating us that's the
focus of tonight's angle all right the
preparations for the date are underway
so what is he going to wear how long
with their conversations last who's
better at Small Talk the president said
he's looking forward uh to meeting uh to
meeting uh with President G and uh and
so not going to get into details uh
about uh this this this meeting that's
going to happen uh in NE this well it's
going to be in San Francisco it's going
to be a constructive
meeting constructive for whom JP Morgan
Goldman Sachs I don't know New York
hedge funds certainly not the American
people but one thing's certain X does
not meet with foreign leaders unless he
wants something that they're prepared to
give him and he wants those Trump
tariffs lifted is the us considering
lowering tariffs or easing sanctions or
making some gesture to make sure that
meeting happens F face this is in
intense competition we want to uh to
move forward with with China we
understand that and intense competition
means uh intense diplomacy that's what
you're going to see uh that's what the
president is going to uh is going to to
be doing and having you know a tough
conversation we're all getting played
here those tariffs they're coming off
when we take National Security actions
using economic tools we do so in
narrowly targeted ways and not choking
off growth in China I knew it for
China's meaningless promises on climate
change Biden's prepared to reward them
by dropping tariffs that are necessary
and that Trump knew were necessary to
offset all of China's rampant trade
cheating this is kind of like a bank
teller handing a gun to a robber in the
middle of a bank heist it's completely
insane you're witnessing a spectacular
sabotaging of America by our own
president by opening our Southern border
destroying our energy Independence all
the inflationary spending and now
surrendering more us manufacturing to
China if they aren't bought and paid for
over at the White House they're all sure
acting like they are now all of them are
making their pilgrimages to Beijing we
saw it all year long with Gavin Nome
winning the prize for most obsequious
that was last week when he wasn't
plowing into Chinese kids playing
basketball he was sucking up to the CCP
even promoting China's electric vehicle
chips which by the way infuriated
California manufacturing Executives back
home now many of you are sitting there
wondering what explains the Democrats
love affair with China well the answer
kind of boils down to this the left
hates America so much right now that
it's going to side with any ideology
that's hostile to us even if that
ideology bans Free Speech commits
genocide and wants essentially women to
stay in a subordinate position and
speaking to that this week president X
told the women's Congress that we should
actively Foster a new type of marriage
and childbearing culture adding that it
was the role of party officials to
influence young people's views on Love
and Marriage fertility and
family now how deliciously ironic is
that liberal are supporting China and
China's supporting the
patriarchy you see how twisted up and
Knots liberals have gotten now while
they brand Republicans by the way as
anti-democratic Biden is sidling up to
the most anti-democratic regime in
history and that's the angle our next
guest has another theory to explain why
Democrats and especially Liberals are so
eager to compromise with a despotic
regime like China now could it be that
many on the left actually prefer how the
CCP rules through fear and repression
which is why they're undermining our
system here at home